wien vor dem neuen lockdown am freitag
verkündet 24 stunden später sind 40.000
auf der straße sie sind gegen alle
maßnahmen gegen den lockdown gegen die
impfpflicht gegen die masken wie man auf
der demo eigentlich tragen muss der 24
jährige wiener jannis darüber entsetzt
und kann kaum fassen was in seiner stadt
und in seinem land gerade passiert
[Musik]
gehen eben versuchen alles richtig zu
machen dabei aber noch soziale kontakte
zu haben und daneben fielen heute nicht
zeigen werden wir alle wieder
eingesperrt und es ist schade eigentlich
ist ein schönes land dann nämlich gerne
nehme aber es wird immer schwerer hier
glücklich zu sein mit den politischen
umständen die wir gerade haben es wird
bereits der vierte lockdown in
österreich und das ruft bei jan dunkle
erinnerungen hervor an den letzten
winter als er ziemlich einsam war
nachdem er und seine freundin sich
getrennt hatten am samstagabend nutzte
die letzte gelegenheit sich mit einer
frau zu treffen außerhalb der eigenen
vier wände das ist die helena studentin
und 20 jahre alt die beiden haben sich
über kinder gefunden und farb liegt
noch kann so leute kennen aber ist die
nächsten monate ist weiß ich nicht weil
beim spazierengehen werde ich wohl hier
niemanden kennen werden bei der trennung
da habe ich einfach wochen monate lang
gemerkt ich kann mich nicht wirklich
ablenken weil ich die möglichkeit habe
rauszugehen neue leute kennenzulernen
[Musik]
der korona lockdown blues soll bitte
nicht nochmal die melodie des winters
werden findet auch helena vielleicht ist
es ja
denn das wird auch im lockdown erlaubt
seinen kontakt zu den engsten
bezugspersonen
was ich weiß ist die definition sehr
schwammig was das angeht
vielleicht bin ich ja auch folien und
habe ganz viele liebhaber
werde ich das der polizei so sagen kann
und sie es mir glauben
dann habe ich alle möglichkeiten ob das
bei helena so gut angekommen ist für
heute trennen sich ihre wege und wer
weiß was im lok da noch passiert an
lockdown der sich in den vergangenen
tagen steigerte erst galt er nur für
ungeimpfte dann sollte er auf salzburg
und oberösterreich ausgedehnt werden am
freitag dann hieß es lock down für alle
im ganzen land wie es bewusst dass wirte
geimpften menschen in unserem land enorm
viel ab firma zusätzlich kündigte
österreich eine impfpflicht an als
erstes land in europa begründet wird das
mit den horrenden instanzen landesweit
2100 bei kindern sogar bei
2.300 die zahl der patienten auf
intensivstationen hat sich seit
monatsbeginn verdoppelt gleichzeitig
landen hier auch menschen die auf
empfehlung von fdp politikern ein
entwurmung mittel einnehmen
wirkstoff der hier in diesem medikament
im skat moral enthalten ist nehme zur
kenntnis dass 28 prozent der
weltbevölkerung
dieses mittel gegen koubek erfolgreiche
nimmt eine falsche behauptung einer
partei die in oberösterreich mit in der
regierung sitzt als folge davon war dass
mittel dort zeitweise ausverkauft
das bundesland ist die hochburg der
korona skeptiker seit kurzem sitzt eine
impfgegner partei sogar im
oberösterreichischen landtag
auch hier gab es am wochenende proteste
gingen lockdown und impfpflicht
in linz kehrt mit beginn des lok downs
trifft es wieder setzen die menschen zu
hause wie in dieser studenten gegen die
meisten die nicht in familien machen das
aus angst vor möglichen nebenwirkungen
und dann hat man sich entführungs
mittelrhein das ist so
es ist schon absurde zuführt auf engstem
raum zwei studentinnen und ihre freunde
die für den walk down mit eingezogen
sind es ist dass menschen sich nicht
impfen weil
mögliche sachen gehört haben und nicht
die fakten gecheckt haben saison
und denkt fange zum zittern weil mir
kommt es vor als würden diese personen
nur an sich selber denken und näht
darüber noch dinge wo es für andere eben
das bedeutet zum beispiel für mich kein
einkommen ihren job als kellnerin hat
anna durch den lock down verloren alle
vier akzeptieren die maßnahme aber als
einzigen weg die zahlen zu senken und
vor nennt geister zu was bei den demos
passiert
nicht nur diejenigen die wir am
lautesten schreien und da wirklich
dagegen sein aber ich glaube nicht dass
das die allgemeine meinung der
bevölkerung in oberösterreich oder
österreich generell wieder spielt anna
und anja haben schon ihr abitur zu
corona zeiten gemacht und fühlen sich um
die schönsten seiten ihrer jugend
gebracht
so viel von
der stadt mehr oder weniger eben sei es
das feiern gehen in jungen jahren oder
irgendwas anderes und du hast oft mit
die möglichkeit dazu
weil wenn man immer gleichen gleis
währungen dann kommt alex lex die vier
kennen sich seit ihrer kindheit den
sommer haben sie in ihrer heimatstadt
war den eltern verbracht und jetzt sehen
sie wieder nur ihre wohnung für die
psychische gesundheit von jungen
menschen ist so etwas gift seien
psychologen partys für junge menschen so
wichtig wie essen weil er es geht um
ganz wichtige entwicklungsprozesse es
geht ums abnabeln von zuhause es geht
ums abnabeln vom elternhaus es geht um
die eigene identität entwickeln und das
geht eben draußen nur mit anderen
menschen und wenn es glück ist auch mit
fröhlichkeit und feiern in wien wollten
sie die letzte party nacht vor dem lok
tor nochmal in vollen zügen genießen jan
feierte am samstag mit freunden stimmung
fröhlich aber nicht ganz unbeschwert
dumm sind sie zu ihm und alles dass
diese ganze situation zu vermeiden
gewesen
was ich damals die pocken ich glaube
sehr wichtig ja
weil ich in einer coolen wg mit coolen
leuten will wo wir zu dritt einfach lust
sich den ganzen tag
irgendwas machen können so einen lockt
dann kann auch spaß machen aber vor
allem die jungen leute sind wieder
gezwungen einfach das beste daraus zu
machen